before we get into electron affinity
let's really quickly review ionization
energy let's start with a neutral
lithium atom with an electron
configuration of 1s2 2s1 a lithium atom
has three protons in the nucleus so a
positive three charge two electrons in
the 1s orbital so here are the two
electrons in the 1s orbital or our core
electrons and one electron in a 2's
orbital this is our outermost electron
our valence electron the valence
electron is shielded from the full
positive 3 charge of the nucleus by the
presence of the core electrons the like
charges repel and these core electrons
repel this outer electron and shield it
from the full positive 3 charge but
there still is an attractive force
between the positively charged nucleus
and this outermost electrons so opposite
charges attract and our outermost
electrons still feels a pull from the
nucleus therefore since the outer
electron is attracted to the nucleus it
takes energy to completely pull away
this valence electron from the neutral
atom so if we pull away the outermost
electron we lose our valence electron
and we're left with a lithium ion with a
positive charge positive one charge
because we still have three protons but
only two electrons now so overall a plus
1 charge since this ionization takes
energy to rip away the electron the
energy the ionization energy is positive
and it's measured in kilojoules per mole
let's compare that with electron
affinity so in electron affinity let's
say we're starting with our neutral
lithium atom again but this time instead
of taking an electron away we are adding
an electron so we would add an electron
to the 2's orbital so we start off with
3 electrons in the neutral lithium atom
we're adding one more so the electron
configuration for the lithium ion would
be 1s2 2s2
so still three positive charges in the
nucleus two electrons in the 1s orbital
but now we've added an electron so we
four electrons total 2 and the 2 s
orbital so let me highlight the electron
that we added in magenta so this is the
electron that we added to a neutral
lithium atom and this electron we know
is shielded from the full positive 3
charge of the nucleus by our two core
electrons in here and so like charges
repel it's also going to be repelled a
little bit by this electron that's also
in the 2's orbital so this electron is
going to repel this one as well but
there is an attractive force between our
positively charged nucleus and our
negative charge on the electron so this
electron that we added steal still feels
an attractive force that's pulling on it
from the nucleus and so if you add this
fourth electron energy is given off and
since energy is given off this is going
to have a negative value for the
electron affinity for adding electron to
a neutral lithium atom it turns out to
be negative 60 kilojoules per mole so
energy is released when an electron is
added and that is because the electron
that we added is still able to be
attracted to the charged nucleus so if
the nucleus has an attraction for the
added electron you're going to get a
negative value for the electron affinity
or that's one way to measure electron
affinity note that the lithium anion has
larger than the neutral lithium atom
it's just hard to represent it here with
those diagrams so as long as the added
electron feels an attractive force from
the nucleus energy is given off look at
one more comparison between ionization
energy and electron affinity and
ionization energy since the outer
electron here is attracted to the
nucleus we have to work hard to pull
that electron away it takes energy for
us to rip away that electron as it takes
us energy we have to do work and the
energy is positive in terms of
ionization energy but for electron
affinity since the electron that we're
adding is attracted to the
positive charge of the nucleus we don't
have to force this we don't have to do
any work energy is given off in this
process and that's why it's a negative
value for the electron affinity electron
affinities don't have to be negative for
some atoms there's actually no
attraction for an extra electron
let's take me on for example neon has an
electron configuration of 1s2 2s2 and
2p6 so there's a total of 2 plus 2 plus
6 or 10 electrons and a positive 10
charge in the nucleus for a neutral neon
atom so let's say this is our nucleus
here with a positive 10 charge 10
protons and then we have our 10
electrons here surrounding our nucleus
so this is our neutral neon atom if we
try to add an electron so here let's add
an electron so we still have our 10
protons in the nucleus we still have our
10 electrons which would now be our core
electrons to add a new electron this
would be the neon anion here so 1s2 2s2
2p6 we filled the second energy level to
add an electron we must go to a new
energy level so it would be the third
energy level would be an S orbital and
there'd be one electron in that orbital
so here is let's say this is the
electron that we just added so we we
have to try to add an electron to our
neon atom but if you think about the
effective nuclear charge that this
electron in magenta feels our answer the
effective nuclear charge that's equal to
the atomic number or the number of
protons and from that you subtract the
number of shielding electrons since we
have 10 protons in the nucleus this
would be 10 and are shielding electrons
would be 10 as well so those 10
electrons shield this added electron
from the full positive charge of
wonderful positive 10 charge of the
nucleus and for a quick calculation this
tells us that the effective nuclear
charge is zero and this is you know
simplifying things a little bit but you
can think about this outer electron that
we tried to add
not having any attraction for the
nucleus these ten electrons shield it
completely from the positive ten charge
and since there's no attraction for this
electron energy is not given off in this
process actually it would take energy to
force an electron on to neon so if we
wrote something out here if we said all
right I'm trying to go from me I'm
trying to add an electron to neon to
turn it into an anion instead of giving
off energy this process would take
energy so we would have to force we have
to try to force this to occur so it
takes energy to force an electron on a
neutral atom of neon and we say that
neon has no affinity for an electron so
it's unreactive it's a noble gas and
this is one way to explain why noble
gases are unreactive this anion that we
intended isn't going to stay around for
long so it takes energy to force this on
to our Neutral neon atom so you could
say that the electron affinity is
positive here it takes energy but
usually you don't see positive values
for electron affinity for this sort of
situation at least most textbooks I've
looked at would just say the electron
affinity of neon is zero since I believe
it is hard to measure the actual value
of this here we have the elements in the
second period on the periodic table and
let's look at their electron affinities
we've already seen that adding an
electron to a neutral atom of lithium
gives off 60 kilojoules per mole next we
have beryllium with a zero value for the
electron affinity that means it actually
takes energies this number is actually
positive and it takes energy to add an
electron to a neutral atom of beryllium
so to think about going from a neutral
atom of beryllium to form the beryllium
anion we looked at electron
configurations neutral atom of beryllium
is 1s2 2s2 and so to form the negatively
charged beryllium anion it would be 1s2
2s2 and to add the extra electron and
must go into a 2p orbital which is of
higher energy and so this is actually
the same thing or very
- neon which we just discussed for neon
the electron configuration was 1s2 2s2
2p6 and to add an extra electron we had
to go to the third energy level we had
to open up a new shell and the electron
that we added was effectively screened
from the full nuclear charge by these
other electrons and a similar thing
happens here for the beryllium anion to
add this extra electron we have to open
up a higher energy p orbital this
electron is on average further away from
the nucleus as effectively shielded from
the full positive charge of the nucleus
and therefore there's no affinity for
this added electron so there's no
affinity for this electron so it takes
energy to form the beryllium anion and
that's why we see this zero value here
for beryllium beryllium has no value for
electron of affinity or it's actually a
very positive value and we just say it
has a zero value next let's look at
boron here so this gives off negative 27
kilojoules per mole and we can see a
little bit of a trend here as we go from
boron to carbon to oxygen to fluorine so
as we go across across the period on the
periodic table more energy is given off
and therefore fluorine has the most
affinity for and electron so as we go
across a period we get an increase in
the electron affinity so the negative
sign this means that energy is given off
so we're really just looking at the
magnitude more energy is given off when
you add an electron to a neutral atom of
fluorine then if you add an electron to
a neutral atom of oxygen and we can
explain this general trend in terms of
effective nuclear charge as we go across
our period we also have an increase in
the effective nuclear charge and if the
added electron is feeling more of a pole
from the nucleus which is what we mean
here by at by increased effective
nuclear charge more energy will be given
off when we add that electron so this
idea explains the general trend we see
for electron that's in
see as you go across a period we get an
increase in the electron affinity we've
already talked about beryllium as an
exception neon as an exception but what
about nitrogen in here we can see that
nitrogen doesn't really have an affinity
for an electron and you'll see many
different values for this one depending
on which textbook you're looking in but
if we look at some electron
configurations really quickly we can try
to explain this so for nitrogen the
electron configuration is 1s2 2s2 and
then 2p 3 so if we draw out our orbitals
let's just say this is the 2's orbital
and then these are the 3 2p orbitals so
we'll just do these electrons here 2
electrons in the 2's orbital and then we
have 3 electrons in the P orbitals so
let's draw those in there if we try to
add an electron to a neutral nitrogen
atom we're adding an electron to one of
these orbitals which already has an
electron in it so adding an electron to
one of these orbitals right the added
electron would be repelled by the
electron that was in there to start with
and this is the reason that you usually
see in textbooks for the fact that this
does not follow the trend nitrogen
doesn't have an affinity for one added
electron so after going through all of
that it's obvious that electron affinity
is a little more complicated than
ionization energy an ionization energy
with a pretty clear trend and it was a
little easier to explain why for
electron affinity going across a period
on the periodic table we see a little
bit of a trend but there are many
exceptions to this and perhaps our
explanations are a little bit too
simplistic to explain actually what's
going on but across a period you see you
do see a little bit of a trend going
down a group is much harder you see more
inconsistencies and it's not really even
worth going over a general trend for
that